mes chers collègues
l'ordre du
s'il vous plaît
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
sur le rapport de la commission mixte
paritaire du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie
je vais demander à chacun des
parlementaires qui brandit une pancarte
de bien vouloir cesser immédiatement
cela est contraire à notre règlement
et à madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc je vous remercie mes chers
collègues mes chers collègues s'il vous
plaît
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues
[Musique]
la séance est suspendue pour deux
minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés
en engageant la responsabilité de son
gouvernement le 15 novembre
1990 lors du débat sur la création de la
contribution sociale généralisée
Michel Rocard avait eu ses mots
les inscrits où chacun d'entre elles
selon sa conscience
permettez-moi de dire que je suis sûr
que ces dispositions réuniraient une
majorité peut-être même une large
majorité
ces mots aujourd'hui je l'ai fait bien
et j'ajoute que si chacun votait selon
sa conscience et en cohérence avec ses
prises de position passée nous n'en
serions pas là cet après-midi
[Applaudissements]
cet après-midi je n'ai pas envie de
revenir sur les échapper personnelles
qui peuvent faire oublier un certain les
positions qu'il défendaient quelques
mois plus tôt avec leur famille
politique
cet après-midi je n'ai pas envie de
revenir non plus sur le comportement de
ceux qui ont tout fait pour bloquer le
débat qui ont refusé d'échanger idée
contre idée programme contre programme
et ce sont contentés
et pliés les insultes les excès et les
attaques et les cris au moment même où
je m'exprime dans son filtre
supplémentaire
ce sont les mêmes qui n'ont cessé de
remettre en cause notre procédure
parlementaire nos institutions et donc
notre démocratie
[Applaudissements]
enfin cet après-midi je n'ai pas envie
de revenir sur le mutisme de ceux à
l'extrême droite de cette émission qui
sont de l'ombre tout au long des débats
qui ont préféré se taire profitant en
silence des outrances des uns et des
revirements des autres
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce que
je veux retenir de ces derniers mois
c'est que nous avons mené depuis
l'automne dernier avec le ministre du
Travail Olivier du sof une concertation
dense avec les organisations syndicales
patronales et les groupes parlementaires
ce que je retiens de ces dernières
semaines c'est que nous nous sommes
donnés les moyens de la discussion et
que vous avez passé plus de temps de
débats sur cette réforme des retraites
que sur chacune des deux précédentes
ce que je retiens c'est l'engagement que
j'ai pris devant vous lors de ma
déclaration de politique générale et
lors de la présentation du projet du
gouvernement pour les retraites toujours
rechercher des compromis
le temps passé à dialoguer avec les
partenaires sociaux et les
parlementaires qui étaient attachés
comme nous à garantir l'avenir de notre
système de retraite par répartition nous
a permis de converger autour de
propositions nouvelles et d'une réforme
enrichie améliorée mais toujours
équilibré
hier la commission mixte paritaire
hormone de la co-construction
parlementaire
composé de députés et de sénateurs de
toutes les sensibilités et où les
soutiens du gouvernement ne sont pas
majoritaires à construire un compromis
ce compromis n'est pas
le c'est le texte du Parlement
[Applaudissements]
ce compromis je n'en partageais pas tous
les points mais c'est le vôtre enrichi
de propositions de la majorité et des
oppositions des deux assemblées et
adopter au Sénat ce matin
ne peut pas prendre le
riz de voir le compromis bâti par les
deux assemblées écartés on ne peut pas
faire de Paris sur l'avenir de nos
retraites cette réforme est nécessaire
[Applaudissements]
aussi parce que je suis attaché à notre
modèle social et parce que je crois dans
la démocratie
c'est sûr votre réforme sur le texte du
Parlement fruit d'un compromis entre les
deux assemblées que je suis prête à
engager ma responsabilité
aussi sur le fondement de l'article de
49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
j'engage la responsabilité de mon
gouvernement sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 modifier par
l'amendement de coordination communiquer
à l'Assemblée nationale dans
quel cas je n'en doute pas à
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
gouvernement répondront une ou plusieurs
notions de censure un vote aura donc
bien lieu comme il se doit et c'est donc
la démocratie parlementaire qui aura le
dernier mot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'Assemblée nationale prend acte de
l'engagement d'un responsabilité du
gouvernement conformément aux
disposition de l'articles 49 alinéa 3 de
la Constitution le texte
qu'est la première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présence en application de l'article 155
alinéa premier de notre règlement le
débat sur ce texte est immédiatement
suspendu ce texte sera considéré comme
adopté sauf une motion de censure est
déposée avant deux mains 15 heures 20 et
voter dans les conditions prévues à
l'article 49 de la Constitution dans
l'hypothèse une motion de censure serait
déposée la Conférence des Présidents
fixera la date et les modalités de sa
discussion la séance est levée